هي الانتخابات البرلمانيه الرابعه التي
تشهدها تونس بعد الثوره لكنها لا تشبه
السابقاتها فالتصويت فيها على الافراد لا
على قوائم حزبيه اقبال المصوتين كان بطيئا
خصوصا خلال ساعات الصباح لكن هيئه
الانتخابات رات في النسب المسجله على مدى
اليوم مؤشرات ايجابيه مقارنه بالمواعيد
السابقه
نعلم ان جزء كبير من الناخبين يتوجه في
الساعات الاخيره ولكن حتى بالمقارنه مع
المواعيد الانتخابيه السابقه بما في ذلك
استفتاء 25 جوليا والانتخابات التشريعيه
لسنه 2019 في هذا المعدل في الساعتين هو
تقريبا المعدل العام المعتمد في المعيد
الانتخابيه في تونس ولم يخلو يوم
الانتخابي من رسائل السياسه فالرئيس اعتبر
هذه الانتخابات فرصه تاريخيه للقطع مع من
وصفهم بمخربي البلاد
واعملوه من اجله
ان نقطع
مع من له هؤلاء الذين نحبوا البلاد وخربوا
ونصبوا انفسهم اوصياء على الشعب التونسي
بطريقه اقتراعا بائده
الانتخابات التي لم يخلو سياقها العام
ايضا من جدل قانوني محتدم بشان الفصول
المعدله من قانونها الانتخابي
الانتخابيه بدون اي مترشح 10 دوائر
التشريعي هذا
المتعلق بانتخابات 17
ديسمبر كان مسار احادي الجانب بدون
تشاركيه في سياقته لم تتوه صفحه
الانتخابات التشريعيه بعد انتهاء هذا
اليوم المرور الى جوله انتخابيه ثانيه
يبدو امرا حتميه في عدد من الدوائر فوقا
للقانون الانتخابي يشترط للفوز بمقعد في
مجلس النواب
طوله المترشح على الاغلبيه المطلقه من
اصوات ناخبي دائرته الرهان سياسي لهذه
الانتخابات يراوح بينما ذهب اليه الرئيس
بالقطيعه مع ما وصفها بمنظومه غلبت عليها
الحسابات السياسيه على حساب مصلحه البلاد
وبين القوى السياسيه المعارضه له التي ترى
ان هذه الانتخابات لن تنتج سوى برلمان بلا
صلاحيات ومزيد من احكام قبضه الرئيس على
مقاليد السلطه ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره
تونس